for the past six months i've been doing
a series of investigative reports on
critical race theory in america's
fortune 100 companies and what i've
discovered is that about a third of the
fortune 100 companies that i can verify
are promoting the principles of crt
including systemic racism white
privilege
this idea that whiteness is synonymous
with evil exploitation and oppression
and one of the companies that actually
was the one of the worst offenders
was american express the premier credit
card company
american express was teaching its
employees that the country was
fundamentally racist that capitalism was
fundamentally oppressive and so as i was
doing these reports i reconnected with
kenny shu an activist and writer who
said that we wanted to do something
about it and he wanted to turn this
investigative reporting into concrete
action so he's launching this campaign
first against american express to try to
get them to
change their programs to
reckon with what they're doing to their
employees and we want a color blind
america treatment of the content of your
character not the color of your skin
so we saw roofo's reporting
on american express and the fact that
they were conducting
critical race training um where they
were asking their where they were
telling their members that capitalism
was racist
and they were
arranging their members on a privilege
hierarchy based on race
um and so we contacted rufo
and rufo gave us access to some of his
sources
and we did our own investigations on
additional sources and discovered that
all of the things that were going on at
american express that he reported was
true and they're worse than ever so we
discovered that american express was the
tip of the iceberg in terms of corporate
wokeness which as you know is a huge
campaign 2022 issue so we decided to get
involved
any successful public pressure campaign
works because it changes public
perception and so a lot of people have a
very good feeling towards american
express it's a kind of a luxury credit
card brand it's used by
business people it has uh i think really
good uh
brand perception or reputation
and the goal of the the un american
express campaign is really to challenge
that idea so american express for
example has now actually
given bonuses
to hiring managers
for
so-called racial equity meaning that
they are giving bonuses to hiring
managers
who hire more blacks
and fire white americans
so you hire black americans you fire
white americans for the sake of equity
you get a bonus you get a financial
incentive to be racist basically to
discriminate on the basis of race i mean
that is something that we opposed